[Music]
welcome back to the red carpet no
how crazy is this guys it's like deja vu
the crowd was electrifying i'm just
proud to be just a small part of it all
charlize's hot pink dior jacket was a
tribute to vin's triple x coat
also in pink jordana brewster wearing a
sequin versace gown
and in f9 out this friday cardi b makes
her debut as lisa a woman from dom's
past
we are very much excited to evolve her
character and to expand it into the
finale she made it just in time
i can't wait what is tyrese's movie
snack i'm old school popcorn
too much butter you got to look at it
and make sure that the whole
top of the popcorn is glistening
paul walker's 22 year old daughter
meadow honored her father by showing up
at the premiere
also on the carpet vanessa and natalia
bryant who told me how her prom night
went
good nice to see you darling as for how
this franchise will end
we do know jason statham makes a return
the
greatest finale in cinematic history
i said juliana's watch like every single
one
but he's watching this one for the first
time he's like mom when i get in the
theater like when can i see uncle vin
so he's like let's go i'm ready if you
are are your babies impressed at all
about mom and fast cars or do they just
not no my kids are so not impressed by
anything that i do
it's really sad they're really into
dance
they go to this incredible dance studio
and then when they come home
they'll like dance in the kitchen
you